try to get one back tonight against 34
year old veteran right-hander carlos
carrasco on the mound for the mets yeah
the veteran has all four pitches
fastball slider cutter and a curve will
mix in the changeup against lefties and
his problem this year matt has been the
first inning eight starts four right
here at city field has given up two
first pitches home runs crazy
a loud boisterous crowd last night same
thing tonight for the series finale
and there's ball four to lemay here
as we mentioned carrasco's command has
been very good despite his first inning
struggles one or fewer walks in all
eight of his starts but he loses the
lead off hitter tonight now you open up
the hole there for the left hand to
hitting rizzo the next 3-2 la mayhew
runs again and it's ball four
back-to-back walks open the game
and carrasco's first start as a met
with multiple walks here comes pitching
coach jeremy hefner a very early visit
judge is really taking considerable time
here something doesn't look right
is he having a contact lens issue
yankees training staff is about to come
out something right here though man this
has taken a long time i think we've all
gone through you know contact lens
hiccups in the past
struck him out
but judge's status is is worth and no
pun intended here it's worth keeping an
eye on he did not look comfortable at
all one out runners still on first and
second standing at 270.
already 25 pitches to start the ball
game four batters into it
and stanton shoots that one into the gap
in right center field that's going to do
some damage
lemay hue being waved around to score
rizzo held it third and it's one nothing
yankees
that is the yankees first hit in the
series with runners in scoring position
they've been old for their last 15
dating back to earlier in the week the
fire still hot with runners at second
and third to run in one gun for joey
gallo
and the pit swung on and hit in the air
to left center field gets in the run
cutting over is mcneil he makes the
catch
and for just the second time in his
career it's a sac fly for joey gallo and
a wonky throw back into the infield that
squirts away and stanton advances on the
play
and the pitch hit on the ground a third
vr to throw across in time to end the
inning
clark schmidt yanks nija first rounder
back in 2017 number 16 overall slowed
down this year because of an elbow
strain
he's got a total of six and a third
innings of major league experience most
of his abbreviated season this year has
been spent in the minors four stops in
the minor leagues this year and making
the biggest start of his life here
tonight
and lindor wraps that softly to first
base for rizzo he'll do it himself vr to
second with one away now here is
conforto
with a runner at second and one man out
but four no it's hard left side that's
gonna get through base hit in the left
center field vr rods third he'll score
standing up and the mets get one back in
the bottom of the first it's now a two
to one yankee lead michael conforto has
been going the other way more often
lately and an rbi single there he drives
in his 46th run
forto stays at first two gun now for
javi baez looking to extend a modest
four-game hitting streak
[Applause]
that's wrapped to third base and a fair
ball long throw from her shell is off
line and infield single for javi baez
so second and third a basic could give
the mets the lead
the pitch is hit on the ground to first
rizzo takes it himself
to end the inning so clark on the hill
and the yankees have a two-to-one lead
we hit the bottom of the second inning
and the pitch hit on the ground to
torres he booted it
so there's an error another error on
torres
jonathan vr walked and was plated in the
first he's got pallara and mccann in
scoring position with one gun he didn't
like the first sign from sanchez now
he's ready to go to work did 3-2 home
one of the breaking ball and struck out
vr with it that shows you a little bit
why the yankees are so high on this
young man clark so with runners at
second and third now run can't score it
and out with two men out and here's
frankie lendore lindor with a swing and
a drive out to right field gallow on the
move still on the
move and it's gone
if francisco's first year as a met could
include a signature moment we just
watched it
and this breaking ball not the good one
that buster was talking about
a little bit of a cement mixer overthrew
it a little fatigued lead off walks and
lead off errors will kill a team well
the mets needed that well here is mccann
the right hand it is i said i would walk
him i i wouldn't take the chance of
giving him another run pitch
swung on high fly to left stanton goes
back he's on the track and he makes the
catch
he had about two or three steps to go to
get to the wall
now one on and one out and that'll bring
up jeff mcneal
and mcneil sends that one into the
corner in right field
let's see if they try it with baez
they're gonna give him the stop sign
and the mets are set up second and third
with one gone base is loaded with one
gun 3-1 pitch to mccann is lifted out to
deep right gallows on the move he makes
the catch it's more than enough to tag
and score baez
and the mets increase their lead to
three runners lead first and third two
out pitch uh ground ball to short taurus
flips to second for the force
well i guess it could be worse the only
thing is the mets added a run so the
yankees down by three
in the inning
one run
two hits here's the one oh to glabor
and the pitch hit in the air to deep
left
back on the wall goes mcneal to the wall
she's gone
it's labor day
glay baturas just did a two-run home run
to love and he makes it a ball game
as the mets now have a 5-4 lead
97 miles an hour coming in in the
two-run jimmy jack fastball foot down
head down boom ba
in the queens
will be francisco lindor who's hit a
three-run homer tonight
when dorts hydride left center field
gardner back looking up this one's going
to go home run francisco lindor has
homered again he has hit two tonight
one from each side of the plate
lindor taunts his best friend urchella
as he rounds the bases yes it is 16th
home run of the year that was a blast
just to the left of straight away center
field as the mets now lead 6-4 stanton
doubled in a run simpson has struck out
deep left center field and this game is
tied
santa maria
and look at stanton taking his sweet
time oh he got some chippiness he's
talking to lindor
now it's on
everybody's out on the field
stanton answering back to lindor we have
a game we have a series if you're going
to talk to talk you better walk the walk
and they're both doing it so this is fun
cisco lindor has brought his own sense
of unity to this game united everybody
to get out of their seats as he
approached don't play and only two mets
in the history have hit three home runs
here at home
oh my gosh
[Applause]
here in the bottom of the egg just the
second ever mets shortstop to enjoy a
three-homer game
and he takes his curtain call right now
time run and scoring position go ahead
run on base for gardner diaz ready his
pitch
swinging strike three
gardner strikes out on a slider two outs
in the ninth and here comes john carlos
stanton you can't draw this up any
better
jam shot pop up
why not lindor putting the finishing
touches
on a memorable night wrapping up the
subway series